yo yo yo
[Music]
it's been a while since we did much
streaming
uh from the road so i thought we'd do
one
people a little bit of time to get in
here youtube's pretty bad about
notifying like twitch is much better
um when you go live those people have to
go a little faster
what up leo
uh i've been listening to i've been
listening to high growth handbook you
know
uh you gotta learn when you when you're
when you're starting
up this boys for
breakout success they gotta tell you
about how to do it you know
are you getting it confused with finland
uh
look look there's a person it's in idaho
what up robin
um yeah it's been a while since we've
done an open pilot cruising stream
um that's a bit fast the speed limit 70.
70. i'm on my way to salt lake city
getting back to work on monday
uh you know
got a lot of we got a lot of growth to
do this year
next um
we have some unbelievable things in the
pipeline
uh can you do 80
there's the refactor model branch i was
driving on yesterday it's not as good
there's a few
bugs in the new model but i think we
know what they are and the cool things
it shows like road edges and red
it detects four lanes uh these things
won't be used to actually control the
car but they will be used for mapping
efforts
we're getting back into mapping but
we're doing it
uh in a very cheap way
and then one of the big things that
we're trying to build out next year is
navigation
so by the end of next year it is my
dream
and i'll look at you when i tell you
about my dream it is my dream
that we will have our first trip to taco
bell
without a disengagement
um yeah right now the speed's limited to
73 it's only going 72. there's a tiny
mismatch between the speedometer and the
retail speed
that's less on yonder than toyota um
[Music]
nah not through the drive-through not
through the drive-through i'll be happy
if it
gets you it's not gonna drive in the
parking lot either but it's gonna get
you to the parking lot
of a taco bell yeah it's gonna do turns
bros
you guys still open pilot can already do
turns if it had enough torque
um just there's you can send uh
you know desires to the model um we have
six desires
there's lane change left lane change
right keep left keep right
the keeps don't really work due to bugs
in the ground truth
but the other two are turn left and turn
right
and if you put those in and you have a
car with sufficient torque
um it will make the turn
i believe i mean we've never tried it
it's not that practical yet
um you know you know
[Music]
uh something something more cameras
something something
all right ready we'll do a lane change
here folks
yeah look at that lane change
speed up a little bit gotta pass this
uh what's that thing carrying it's kind
of like some some girders
building a bridge somewhere bro
um so i've been driving i've put almost
2 500 miles on open pilot on this road
trip
um it's almost perf
at least for like any boring kind of
roads i was using it up in the mountains
in colorado very impressed
places where no stock lane keep in fact
i did have i did have one place where i
ran into can errors
which are hopefully going to be fixed in
the new neo s so i fell back to the
stock hyundai system
you just can't it's unusable when you
expect a system where touching the wheel
is an
anomaly and not a frequent occurrence
it's so much of a different mentality
that you have to be in
you know it's the hardest thing to
convey i think we
i saw that tweet where we showed open
pilot driving through a rainstorm
and like a dense rainstorm like some
florida
some florida downpour kind of rain
uh how do you convey how do you convey
that you're just
so much better than all the stock lane
keeping assist
um so i'm not on i'm this is just master
not on any of the new
um hadeeb's been doing a great job
uh stability reducing cpu usage
one of the things that's going to come
in neos 15 is we're going to down clock
the cpu slightly
so we should be able to get much better
thermals out of these things with a
slightly down clock cpu
uh
messenger track didn't know what that
means
but yeah we're chilling if anyone has
questions it's question time i got an
interview
at three i'm in mountain time here
um volvo support oh there are dozens of
you wow doesn't that sounds like
something to commit engineering to
um oh when i was sick in january c
yes no i got an antibody test i don't
think i've had covet
um i think i'm immune though you know
ah i just think i just think like i have
natural natural immunity or something
what what's going on here why did
everyone get in that lane
oh because there's a thingy over there
um there are dozens of volvo people
yeah so i don't know about flex right
what i think about the new apple maps
maps pretty good
my eyes are on the road it would yell at
me if my eyes were
did he yell at me
[Music]
good job uh don't hit any cones you know
be kind of embarrassing if you hit a
cone
yeah you know the new laneless policy
should keep it a little more to the left
here
like i would like slightly more left
once we get better with playing this out
we're rolling through a construction
site here
i've got my hand on the wheel right now
that's why i'm getting that beat
i'm just pulling it more to the outside
of the lane than it wants to go right
now
this will be fixed once we depend more
on laneless
so it's a trade-off um
you can trade off like rock solid
stability for being able to deviate
slightly outside of the lanes in cases
like that
uh so you don't have to explicitly
detect the traffic cones we don't
explicitly detect uh
yeah moving over for semis and stuff
yeah that's um
i mean you can switch right now you can
go in and you can disable the lanes
and it should already do that with the
path but
then it won't feel as stable in the
center of the lanes so let's try it off
uh but we can work to to get better at
both um with new model releases you know
i've been working really we've been
working really hard on the new
on the new model um hd maps is good
so the one of the other things the new
model does is the new model doesn't just
have two lanes it has four lanes
as well as two road edges and this is
largely possible thanks to what people
have been doing in the uh comma 10k
project
so if you check out comma 10k
you can see people
contributing and now it detects tons of
lanes
ah my face is uncertain because the
phone is being held in the way of the
camera
see
wow
jordan peterson as a comma
it's news to me
uh yeah but so once we have once we have
four lane outputs and road edges
we should even be able to use just the q
logs
to stitch together good enough hd maps
we care about lane accuracy for two
reasons um not not we're not gonna use
the maps for any kind of um
policy but we can do two things for the
map
we can know where disengagements are
more likely to happen i think this is
going to be
a requirement for level three i think
it's gonna be very hard to do level
three without a large fleet and maps
because or at least some kind of
implicit maps saying
i have been in this lane ten thousand
times and have never made a
mistake ah
so but again it doesn't actually
influence the policy it influences kind
of the meta policy
oh i wish you two kept the chats around
because you guys post and then it goes
away when i look over
um
do you have any ideas why the driving
assistant systems are so bad because
they're very hard to build
um
they're oh we can get up the speed a
little bit um
they're very hard to build there's so
much subtlety that goes into it
for example uh so unfortunately
my windshield got hit by a rock and you
can see my crack in the windshield right
so this sucks because you know we're
gonna have to get the windshield
replaced
and replacing the windshield requires
recalibration of the factory eight ass
camera and it's because they just you
know they didn't write a good
calibration routine
it's something we put a lot of time into
um
there's a ton of subtlety in being able
to deal with banked roads
uh there's a lot of subtlety in what the
definition of elaine is
if you're trying to do things based on
lanes and cars you will hit a ceiling
pretty fast
i think the ceiling on lanes and cars is
super cruise
like if you're using lanes and cars
explicitly you can never build something
better than supercruise
and you'll always be you always have to
geofence to places like this
uh was this road uses training data
honestly i have no idea
we don't really track that that doesn't
matter
um but it works
uh make sure we don't we don't actually
explicitly exclude roads
in the test
uh where's the cowboy hats in the
backseat
drive around with the cowboy hat oh
i don't want to bring back general chat
i think i think that as we grow we need
more structure in the discord
i think there's lots of places online to
should talk about self-driving cars
uh what gpus we use for not are not a
data center
well well in our in our in our in our
small research cluster
we use 1080 tis
and i would love to have some 30 80s but
i don't know if you guys followed that
this morning
what a fiasco did i buy all the 3080s i
wish
i don't think we got a single 30 80. um
despite everybody
waking up my speed limit's 55 hanging
i'm gonna slow down here
uh despite everybody waking up and
trying to get their orders in
and we all spammed the website we spam
best buy
i don't know i don't think there were
any 3080s i think it was just a troll
they just went to nvidia employees
all right hang on i got to pay attention
here
more so than usual how do i use cuadros
how rich you think i am you know we
didn't we didn't we didn't raise buku
dollars
what's your weibo question again sorry
let me just
i gotta deal with this we gotta uh we're
driving
into a construction zone
i mean i don't have to deal with i'm not
doing anything but we just gotta pay
extra careful vigilant attention we
don't wanna hit a cone you know
the cone would feel bad you see
i wish our policy could move us slightly
more to the left side of the lane here
not bad and it will do it here look it
does it so well there oh look when the
lane lines disappear oh
that was beautiful um
but yeah like if one of those cones are
slightly out in the road you can see the
car in front of me has moved over maybe
maybe 20 30 centimeters
um i wish youtube kept the chat around
because i'd like to respond to all your
things but i'm going to miss them
because i can't really look at the chat
right now
so watch it's gonna move over here it's
gonna move over oh so nice
so nice let me get it back in this lane
put my speed back up
sometime i feel when i'm driving with
open pilot i feel like i'm a conductor
you know
what was your question
if you just literally paste the same
thing again i know it sucks but you do
did i start with my own pc as a training
machine oh yeah
yeah the first thing was training on one
titan x that i had in my machine
the driver facing camera be fooled by
the sunglasses it's not going to track
your eyes so yeah i mean
um if you if you manage to fall asleep
staying you can't see through the
sunglasses
uh so if you manage to fall asleep
looking perfectly straight with
sunglasses
it won't catch you um
but no i mean you can it still detects i
think you saw it you saw a trigger on me
a few times
we use meta reinforcement learning i'm
not sure what that is
uh so we're closer to level five yeah
yeah wherever exclusive thank you
waymo question why does waymo not use
mu0 stuff ah
next year we're really moving into museo
stuff
the the big thing on top of my board
in my office is thinking and vision
features
um we made up we made a hire uh recently
too
who's gonna who's gonna pie torch expert
he's gonna help with this stuff
we are how does it behave with no lane
lines
sometimes it behaves better i mean if
you saw if you saw that cone scenario it
actually behaved better
uh when it has the lane lines it uses
them to enforce dead center
we'll we'll figure out ways to trade off
this policy nicely um
humans look at look at this guy like
look at this guy in front he just
drifted over the lane line
uh and you know you'd be upset if your
open pilot did that
so it's
again put a mimic human policy exactly
but we'll figure it out
oh my hackers they're not real uh thank
you
where does comma ai fit now that car
drivers are working on their own
self-driving
they've been working on their own
self-driving for five years the problem
the problem is and i've been listening
to high growth handbook and it becomes
really obvious what the problem is
um
let's imagine you wanted to paint the
sistine chapel
right and you're not even a clever
startup
you're you're waymo right or cruise
you're you're you're like look at calvo
right
you know he had success in the past with
startups he has this startup mentalities
and and it's no longer disruption if
you're inside of this box
right there can't be formulaic
disruption that's an oxymoron
and self-driving cars
are not going to be solvable by a team
that views their people
almost as like fungible tokens
the the approaches that worked
previously to managing
software engineers are no longer going
to work
uh when we have things that aren't just
there's no more boilerplate code anymore
um boilerplate code has all been
replaced
by well we've gotten to a very high
level of abstraction with things
uh you know the just just the python
ecosystem and the
um did willam ever get as a dark modded
uh yeah i think he did um
you're if you're a skilled reverse
engineer you too can have a torque
modded car
um there's almost no more boilerplate
code
and in with machine learning it doesn't
require a lot of code it requires a
small amount of very good code
so of course yeah ml is holistic exactly
and it's holistic nature just like
building a great piece of art imagine
the statue of
david was made by a committee it
wouldn't be beautiful
it wouldn't be good it wouldn't be
quality and that's what you get
from these companies they're built by
committees the person who builds the
lane detectors not the person who built
the car detector who builds a cone
detector
who builds it just yeah
there's not enough you know you can't
build this like you build crud apps
um do i think open pile is beautiful
yeah
uh i think
[Music]
it you know it wasn't at the beginning
at the beginning
it was kind of stupid code um
oh this guy's going mad slow should we
change lanes around them
like 50 miles an hour i don't know
um yeah i think this whole thing
common itself it's a work of art
you know what kind of what kind of a
company is this
right it's a hacker company it's a
company founded on the principles watch
this
lane change without even a lane line oh
that's unreal
oh how does it do that what is a lane
change without
lane line oh how are you going to put
that in your definition manual delphi
pro tip you can't
[Music]
oh yeah look now we're cruising around
these people let's go
i'm just gonna steer right to start the
lane change
let my car do the rest
exactly exactly
um well hacker culture has has values
that i think are very amenable to
solving this problem
uh hacker culture doesn't have if you're
trying to build like an e-commerce
platform to empower
no that's not built by hackers
built by psychopaths man
when you look when you look and i've
read the code for all of them
and you look at the code for windows and
the code for mac os and the code for
linux
windows and mac os windows especially
windows is
so unreadable it is so
inelegant and you can tell
that it was
you know built by people who don't
really care
um and there's a reason linux is taking
over the world it took a long time but
[Music]
better there remember mac os is is open
source
um at least the kernel is and
it's better but it still has deep
inelegance about it
um well so predicting the next frame the
problem
with predicting the next frame is what's
your loss function
[Music]
your loss function can't be the beauty
of predicting the next letter is
categorical cross-entropy is so good
um what's zero i don't know what that is
but yeah we're moving a lot more to
thinking in vision features
uh implementing some user stuff dynamics
we models to rewrite everything open
palette is a project and it will
eventually be
done
right or at least feature completely
um we're going to have to have
navigation
[Music]
um and the the second part of that
mission the shipping uh delivering
shippable intermediaries is kind of just
to keep us honest
right sometimes i get a little too pie
in the sky when i'm like oh it's all
going to be one magic trick it's all
going to be one mu zero
um but i mean you might see that and
that's how deep mine may look externally
but i'm sure there were many
iterations that they didn't publish of
those things
and i figure you know why not publish
them switching from c
plus plus to c who would code and see
anymore
all right stuff i'll empower this
open pilot is mostly c-plus plus
it is true that the main control loop is
still in python now
but there's no reason not to
it's not a phone mount we should put
those in all our cars
i will auto tuning use lqr and the pid
controller is mostly fine
how's the navigation app going we're
still hiring
uh for it no we're not implementing
counter factuals yet and i think even
the first round of the dynamics model
still won't um the counterfact
our current loss function probably
doesn't support counterfactuals
we know how to do it but you know it's
all gradual
level five is not really more of an
insurance issue if you build something
that's 10x better than people
insurance is easy no rear view camera
have i tried rust you know rust is the
new haskell
controversial opinion rust is the new
haskell and it's going to go the way of
haskell
go is inelegant crap yet you know
[Music]
got a big following rust is beautiful
and elegant so is haskell
um dynamic follow distance no i'm not
implementing anything like that
you guys are just gonna if you want that
you're just gonna have to wait for end
to end longitudinal
and to wait for anti-longitudinal you're
first going to have to wait for true end
to end lateral
like we have an end-to-end lateral
policy but it's not yet good enough to
completely remove the lane lines
that's going to be the first step
harold's always saying there is no
reason why our car does not drive
perfectly on a highway without lanes
and he's right uh so you know until we
solve that problem
i'll walk before you can run my speed
limit went down apparently
now this is this is where they love to
pull you over you know this is
this is where they're like oh yes oh we
would make the speed limit
very fast and we will make it very slow
for no apparent reason
except that we can have our cops sit
there and give tickets
so you know we got to uh
hang on i'm gonna take over here i'm
just gonna accelerate a little
all right all right
and then we have to get on the 15
south
oh we're going to go to argo really
try to meet their quota uh yeah we think
mapbox will be involved
the navigation stuff is very early on um
if you're interested in working on that
we are
hiring aggressively for that we
basically have to build
out that team from scratch um i think
it's going to be a three or four person
team
uh who's going to come to own all of the
open pilot
uh ui uh ux
and and navigation and making sure it
integrates seamlessly
[Music]
and then we think what you're going to
do we'll be able to enter your
destination
from the uh
from the device but we think most people
are just gonna use the comma app
um you know i think hopefully we can
like work with apple to get integrated
as a navigation app hopefully that's not
too hard
like if you're in like airbnb you could
just say like you know navigate with
camo
why is the city listed on the home
screen always wrong nobody works on that
[ __ ]
i'm sorry um it's all kind of terrible
no one works on it
uh we're hiring we have money now
we have profit now uh we'd love to hire
yeah well there's a common app hopefully
you guys already have it you'll just be
able to like click on your car
and then you'll have like a default car
selected so you'll just
it'll be from your phone it's kind of
the point of the experience and the
phone will kind of push it to the device
and the device will do the navigation
for you
yeah we've been profitable or close to
profitable all year
uh we had an actually profitable q1
um our q2 we ended up with more money in
the bank account than we started it with
but partially that was thanks to um you
know free government money
uh and then things look good for q3
we're we're spending there's a lot of
layout in q3
uh for a new
now for your watch the real
legit linux phone oh speed limit 80 hell
yeah bros
oh let's go fast
have any car manufacturers shown
interest they have no idea how to do it
uh yeah of course they've shown interest
they have no idea how to show interest
properly
um they show interest by reaching out
through their business development arm
and that's not gonna work um the way
that
they're actually going to show interest
is they're going to get ignored
repeatedly when their stupid business
development arm reaches out because you
know what
and i'll say it wow maybe this is not
that appropriate for a work stream but
kona is not their [ __ ]
you know a lot of companies think
startups are their [ __ ]
and they think oh this startup oh this
startup will we'll we'll we'll take
whatever little crumbs we want to give
them
no i'm gonna disrupt you
you know think about this can we buy
ford
i mean how much do we have to grow in
order to buy ford
[Laughter]
you know well actually the other
question is how much does ford have to
shrink
for us to buy for right we grow for
drinks natural order of things
you think i'm responding to some
low-level bd person who's like
we are very interested in what you're
doing if you could pretty schedule a
call so we could learn
more i'm not educating you for free man
thousand bucks
thousand bucks i'm happy to educate you
but it's a thousand bucks um
phony calls have been a hot selling item
but um now you can say like look look
this is arrogance right like
why are you talking like this you know
uh obviously
but i mean look at tesla right
look at tesla imagine tesla was like
well all we want to do is supply
batteries and drive trains to bmw
no why do that
um oh well and then yeah that's the
other aspect of it too i'm not sure
these business p
business development people are actually
interested at all in
integrating open pilot in next year's
toyota corolla or even the toyota
corolla five years from now
they want to declare partnerships so
they can like they play some like stupid
game that i don't really understand
um so no i mean here's how it's going to
work
um what's going to happen
is and it is already happening in some
companies you know we track this better
than they think
uh i think
i think every major car company now has
bought common devices
um and their engineers are going to
start
you know one of their engineering
managers
is is going to hear about this and
they're going to have a team the
exploratory team for open pilot
and the exploratory team for mobile
pilot is going to try to get open
pilot working on their car or they're
going to reverse engineer it they're
going to read the code
and then when these people reach out
these are the people who are going to
talk to
these are the people who i'm interested
in talking to once
they have shown that they have like a
serious team of a couple of engineers
working on open pilot integration with
the car
we'd love to work with you and here's
how we're going to work with you get up
you know wow wouldn't it be great if
toyota submitted a pull request
little thing on the hyundai actually let
me see if it's fixed there's a chance
fixed upstream if i tap
no it's still broken um so if i tap the
blinker
the blinker state that we're actually
measuring for the hyundai's
is whether the physical blinker is
depressed not whether the light is
blinking
so i can't do a tap lane change on the
hyundai um
this is my very minor bug uh it has no
it has no real
implications um but it'd be nice it was
fixed in fact if someone wants to submit
a pull request for it now
uh i'd appreciate that but wouldn't it
be great
uh see so when i tap you see that steer
left to start lane change only appears
for
such a short amount of time even though
the blinker keeps going
wouldn't it be great if hyundai
submitted a pull request to fix that
um yeah
and that's that's how i'd like to work
with these companies
and then start okay you want to start
building your own open pilot hardware to
integrate or you want to make open pilot
work on your hardware
we're happy to work with you on that
like i'm interested in working with you
on that but you have to come to me
speaking that language
if you come to me speaking a different
sort of language
uh it's you know we have no interest
kama has
zero interest in in in working with
those kind of people because
it's
really a brokenness in their org
structures and some companies are going
to be able to fix this brokenness
uh and they're going to succeed and
there are still going to be car
companies around
you know samsung made phones long before
android um
i think even huawei used to make like
like bar phones that were clones of
nokia or something i'm not exactly sure
about that but um
acceptance rate is like two percent are
you mean for comma yeah it's harder to
get into common than harvard
um
watch out for nails on the road well i
got hit by a rock in montana
all right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna do a passing maneuver here let's
go
auto lane change does my i'm not getting
tired it's getting a little tired
um yeah he was hugging the terence tower
all right all right
what would the world do with the
non-geniuses all right they're off topic
off topic off topic
no i don't think the crack can be filled
because it's longer than a dollar bill
that's what they say
um why do you need gps returning we
don't
um
gps is not the gps is used for um
it's just used for calibration really
i feel negatively about a video buying
arm for the reasons that everybody else
has talked about it
would you work with corporates that have
dedicated innovation labs no
i mean if they if they reach out if
toyota innovation lab reaches out
i i think those companies are structured
in a way
that those things are basically vanity
projects uh
no i mean look our company com is a
mission driven company
um we're not we're not focused on uh you
know maximizing revenue or maximizing
profit or maximizing prestige or
we're focused on solving self-driving
cars um
they're part of solving self-driving
cars there's a technical aspect to it
there's a deployment aspect to it
uh if you have one self-driving car you
can kind of say you solved it but
obviously i'd like to to ship it um
our old slogan was ghost riding for the
masses
uh can i ran a bit about tensorflow yeah
we're switching up by torch
see it tensorflow
um let's move let's let's let's move the
phone
over here for a little bit yeah but then
you guys can't see the open pilot you
see
i mean if we continually show the
product on stream by the way
if you guys haven't bought one yet buy a
comma two they're 999 dollars
uh do we need a designer only if you can
code
um like just just somebody who stops at
the figma sketches no
but if you can take that and you can um
implement that in qt or html5
yeah we're interested and you go through
a different process then uh
yeah reach out um you go through a
different process we're not going to put
you through aggressive programming
challenges
maybe we'll do some like storyboarding
kind of stuff uh
yeah but yeah if you can code
if you have yeah like like you think you
could do qt or react or that kind of
stuff
we're interested total miles driven by
open pilot
uh i think the website says 25 million
we're probably close to 30. it goes
really fast now
i mean i added i added 3 000 myself
at least i will by the time this trip's
over
uh yeah i think nvidia's purchasing of
arm is going to accelerate the adoption
of risk five
react react native well
it's all the same
utilize all the driving data no um our
current
model is trained on i think this model
is trained in like 250 000 segments
so it's 250 000 minutes of driving
the new one is 400 and hopefully by the
end of the year we'll be at a million
high precision gps is needed for
calibration to understand
how the car is moving through space you
can do this with other sensors but the
gps just helps a lot
um harold explained this to me you know
i want to use like visual odometry to do
a lot more stuff
and then like when you look at the drift
of visual odometry even in the
state-of-the-art papers
kind of has exceeded the state of the
art now we do have the best pose net in
the world by far
but um the pose net isn't like we know
how the car moves like that
but it's still uh nothing over any sort
of distance compared to gps
uh yeah we going fast this is good this
is good we're making progress
in salt lake city tonight i love when
the arrival you know the arrival has
been ticking down
i do have to stop for lunch at some
point and i also have a phone call
at three with a candidate
my dead reckoning you can dead reckon
they can dead reckon
very well but you know it's always nice
to have a gps
uh to help you out yeah pigeons they're
integrated in everything
uh we ship it's the same the same gps
that was in the gray pandas in the uh is
in the common two
yeah we're doing fine
uh how does the loss curve look over
increasing distance
on a road like this you'll get out too
so we go into 192 meters
or 10 seconds
[Music]
um oh the stream of what a software
engineer does this is twitch you know
this is youtube this is comma related
you know
you realize something our investors
don't really care about us you know
they're still look
basically invested in waymo look at that
right
just shows that i mean do you believe in
disruption or not
every time every time you hear this
every time you hear this
where it's like this is it man these
tech companies they're going to be
unstoppable
no they're not
right google facebook like wow
okay you people are like oh but
microsoft and apple are still around
yeah but for every microsoft and apple
there's all those 90 error companies
97 tech companies that are not around
anymore
right like you picked the two that
succeeded there's so much survivorship
bias
right these companies are all going to
fail at some point
oh but google they're unstoppable they
acquire all their competition
google can't even recognize their
competition
um yo okay i will i will show for a
second by the way if any of you guys
have used
uniswap ever you can go get 400
free unicoins i got like my upi
last night i'm just hanging out last
night and
i got i made like um five hundred
dollars
in free crypto that was handed out by
uniswap you know like this shit's all
the future man
and i love i love the disdain and the
mockery for uniswap on some of those
things
you guys took vc money it's disgusting
you know sushi swap didn't take any pc
money
i love it you know i love it you're
seeing the future already
um it was uh someone on twitter
you know i forget i forget exactly what
it was it was a little it was a little
out there
um but they said like
you no longer have the the market
selection procedures no longer work at
all to determine what's good
um all you have is kind of consensus
and comma is that consensus
the future's written in salinity
salinity is here to stay for way longer
than we'd like
you know like viper's not going to get
traction there's going to be formal
analysis tools around solidity
i i don't want to go off a tangent of my
crypto but
i'm very bullish on the space
why won't we support grey panda forever
um
because of fingerprinting 1.0 grey
pandas are going to go away pretty soon
black pandas
as much as i want to deprecate eons
i mean eon eon classics will be
deprecated
um gray pandas will be deprecated black
pandas and an eon gold
yeah you know
we're going to become the only problem
with you're going to run into with the
black panda and neon gold
is we're going to become more aggressive
about the wheel touch at night
driving alone to relax man big driving
chills chill
why not fly it's not about the
destination it's about the journey
i think nvidia buying arm is a threat to
the industry no
i think i think that what nvidia buying
arm is going to do
risk five is coming around just in time
uh you know chris latin is now working
at uh si5
to build tooling around that stuff um
in a way if you've heard about like
accelerationist philosophy
nvidia buying arm is just going to lead
to arms demise faster
you didn't believe i'm driving with
autopilot take a look
i haven't touched the wheel in forever
and you don't believe
believe believe believe believe believe
um
i would feel better knowing that it was
like monitoring that truck next to me
it's not like if that truck swerved a
little it should swerve too
and you know you know multi-camera
multi-camera blah blah blah blah
or something like that yeah
all right let's get past this truck
blinker touch
on blinker
is comma just a meme no kama's an
incredible piece of software
have i seen silicon valley yeah
yeah yeah yeah multicam yeah guys we're
gonna build multicam eventually we're
not ready yet
we're not ready there's so much
improvement still to be done with a
single camera
thinking of vision features if you can't
solve the problems with a single camera
multi-camera's not going to help you do
you need multi-camera yes
but we have multi-camera sure get ready
to pay out the ass for you know
it's going to cost a lot of money
um you know what you can decide i mean
we're going to let the consumers decide
do you
we're going to sell common 2s for a long
time um
comma twos comma twos are here to stay
for a while like i said
it's 1.0 hardware um you know people are
like oh the thermal issues the thermal
issues
we're fixing them in the next neo s with
uh
with uh a slight down clock to the cpu
i don't want to put anything on the roof
as soon as you're outside the cabin you
expose yourself to
all sorts of annoyances
now the thermals you have to tolerate
out there or even crazier
i mean that's that's operating thermals
not just uh
i mean at least we can say system
overheated uh
and we can fall until because you know
it turns out electronics are comfortable
in the same range as as humans the same
like temperature range
um i wonder why that is what if that's a
fundamental fact about the universe or
if that's
uh yeah you know you only lie to
yourself
um if you fake things yeah no and we're
gonna let we're gonna let people decide
right
if you think of the comma two as like
ap1 hardware
uh is there eventually gonna be ap2
style hardware yeah it's gonna cost more
is your company a billionaire probably
probably not yet um
so a we have a
very hard lower bound on comma's
valuation at 200 million
i'm not going to go into why but that is
a very real lower bound
um upper bound on commas valuation
you can make arguments for a billion i
think next year billion is going to
become
even more obvious and is going to become
kind of the accepted valuation maybe
even a little bit higher
uh if we get some of these things
working thinking and vision features
works
you know
um if by design more expensive yeah yeah
you want to buy the parts that are rated
for higher temperature ranges they cost
more
there's more work in qual all that sort
of stuff
[Music]
no computer can work on venus i don't
think that's
true i mean you just have to
[Music]
i think you'll just have to build like a
cabin for it right
i don't know i don't know what the
fundamental limitations are for like
designing high temperature silicon and
stuff
um
i'm holding the wheel a little bit
because i don't want to hit a cone
yeah it's a dash cap and that beeps and
that shouldn't be
i was complaining about why that beeps
we're gonna get better at it
willa mentioned the alert reduction
project for zero eight we're gonna try
to reduce the number of spurious alerts
i don't know that much about graphene
now nothing roof mounted nothing goes on
the roof
you know you know do you know how happy
our localization team would be
if we could put the gps antenna on the
roof oh they'd be so happy you know
you lose the signal is so attenuated by
the shady windshield
but yeah i'm not holding the wheel
anymore
i'm like if it hits a cone it's a cone
it's like an icon
uh does it record the driver facing
camera recording is optional
what they closed the highway
all right i gotta go i gotta figure out
why the highway's closed
thank you all for watching
um we'll close the highway
i gotta figure out how to get around
this um maybe
now's about time to eat some lunch too
all right thank you all for watching
we appreciate all of you we are hiring
especially if you're interested in
building navigation
give me a job at comma dot ai um
or coming i slash jobs or if you think
you're really good just email me
uh georgia coming out
bye
you